[музика]
за втомимося його харчуванням і кандидатку
президента франції вигляд правої партії
національний фронт марін ле пен bottom і
[ __ ] в польшу ми турі виборі
він aqua на програм до цього іншого ле
пін проплив був би тим за зовнішню
політику як кардинально види різанина і
тиві смаку париж а сьогодні вона хоче
вийти шенгену нато і організувати
референдум ще до виходу фронтіс
хочу брюссель на галявину умова членства
україни у євросоюзі
призначено антиєвропейську риторику лапин
платила своїм асистентам зарплату за
європейських fondue
ще й фінансовий скандал пов'язані з пози
q і російського банку для своєї та партії
дпн завидного місця сумки в росію з
косово nissan тип бабі ши он вона поважай
анексію криму на законну
і називає і острів територію Росії
ура тепер у могили пен прогноз творить і
3 про світлові і дер фраз з трампом то
путіним кандидату президенти
правоцентристської партії республіканців
франсуа фійон по вбити я буду вас за
зовнішню політику у відході ніж вимкненої
за на тарісі владної України шляхом іван
і степан схожі і він також виступає за
зближення з росією в те скошування
санте
разом стивен піт крес речі видно сни
США для нього важливі речі
фійон дзвіночок рифу раз поливання
конфлікту на донбасі та
і готові та спи вру битва за росію рахунок
про сир їм фійон протона дай мені українці
плану взагалі до членства в звинувачення і винні
адже на бачила на і
перспективи
стукіт україни доїсть
це бахром на тому місці на завищені
канада від півдня річкових президентських
виборів emmanuel macron успішну Францію
побачити вище в рамках is when виступаючи за
заощадження брами шенгену
і проти буде і кордонів лише краї нам
Європи macron за глибиною інтеграції в
Євросоюзі з впевнений але Європа ecostat на
замовлення today with сонячних загрос
матрона назвала прагматичному видно шину
до Росії і доки винний зону ато в
москву про кібератаки російських хакерів
на роботу його штабу та фейків але ви на
зберігай його в російських ЗМІ
wingo дає франція травня до 3 тис.
санкції проти Росії